[Music]
where have we seen rancor writing before
what's up with that brain spider your
burning book of boba fett questions
answered as we explore the show's many
easter eggs
during boba's lesson on rancours with
danny trejo's character in episode three
it's mentioned that the witches of
dathomir used to ride rancors which are
actually native to the outer rim planet
the reference is likely a nod to the
night sisters of dathomir who were
featured prominently in the star wars
animated series the clone wars in both
canon and legends lore the night sisters
and witches of dathomir were lethal
female warriors who shunned much of
technology in favor of tapping into and
wielding the planet's natural channels
of dark magic they first appeared in the
courtship of princess leia in 1994 which
is now a non-canon legends novel the
most famous night sister is asajj
ventress who has spent time as a jedi
padawan a sith assassin and a bounty
hunter
in the season finale boba fett
triumphantly rides in atop his pet
rancor to save the day from the pike
syndicate it's a callback to the witches
of dathomir but it's also a nod to
another star wars character who was
recently revealed as boba fett's clone
sister in the bad batch season 1 we
learn that boba whose clone name is
alpha has a clone sister named omega in
episode 5 the group takes a mission to
retrieve a young rancor which omega ends
up bonding with in writing just like a
much older boba does in book of boba
fett
the third episode of the book of boba
fett has a couple of fun nods to 1983's
return of the jedi first immediately
after the title card in chapter three
the show cuts to a nighttime scene of a
wart outside boba's palace using its
tongue the giant frog-like creature
quickly snags a womp rat and bird at the
same time this scene is remarkably
similar to the one in return of the jedi
an exterior shot of jabba's palace with
the twin sons of tatooine sitting in the
background and a wart snagging his
dinner with his long sticky tongue the
other return of the jedi nod is a blink
and you'll miss it moment when one of
the youth bikers crashes into a painting
being carried out of a building and rips
it in half pause the episode at that
moment and you'll get a better glimpse
of what the painting is jabba the hutt
on his throne surrounded by his old
lackeys the painting is actually an
in-universe version of star wars artist
ralph mcquarrie's original work
in episode 3 boba's cyberpunk youth
biker gang goes on a high-speed chase
through the streets of mo's espa to
catch the mayor's major domo but while
the chase and reveal of the mayor's
involvement with the pikes drives the
book of boba fett's story forward the
speeder bike crash also features a
subtle but sweet callback to star wars
rebels when the major domo crashes his
land speeder slams into several crates
of a reddish-orange fruit called a
melorun this fruit was a key ingredient
in early episodes of rebels and were
later established as general hera
syndulla's favorite and one of zeb's and
ezra's first missions together on rebels
includes them being sent to find the
fruits on lothal where mailerons don't
grow
the book of boba fett chapter 4 had a
fun cameo for music fans as bass
guitarist and singer-songwriter stephen
thundercat bruner appeared as the
modification artist known simply as
modifier thundercat's character seems
like the go-to man for the job of
modifying your body with sleek droid
parts and his handiwork appears to be
very popular among the youth of tatooine
in the gathering storm modifier is the
one who works on fennic and gives her
mechanical parts in her stomach to save
her life he also sports a cool battle
droid hand that he can switch out with
different tools depending on the job
he's doing
one of the most exciting returns in the
book of boba fett episode 5 is the n1
star fighter also called the naboo
starfighter these sleek gold and silver
ships were constructed for defense and
security and were used as escort crafts
for the queen of naboo during the
prequel era the n1 starfighter was most
famously seen in star wars the phantom
menace as an attack craft during the
trade federation's invasion of naboo a
young anakin skywalker flies an n1
starfighter during the battle and helps
destroy a droid control ship to help the
naboo to victory in return of the
mandalorian din jarin helps pelimoto fix
up an n1 starfighter as a replacement
for his destroyed razor crest at first
he calls it a pile of junk but he learns
during a test flight that the
decades-old ship still packs quite a
punch
while tatooine might seem like a barren
wasteland that any farm boy would be
happy to escape from the planet was a
bit of a cultural hub when it came to
pod racing in the phantom menace a young
anakin flies through the dunes and
caverns of tatooine to victory in the
bunta eve classic one of the most
dangerous sections of the bunta eve
classic pod racing track was becker's
canyon a dry riverbed that included
winding stretches and tight turns around
towering desert rock formations in the
book of boba fett chapter 5 mandalorian
din jaron takes his refurbished n1 star
fighter for a test flight through
becker's canyon there's even a shot of a
womp rat resting on a rock before the
starfighter speeds through the area a
nod to luke skywalker's quote about how
he used to bullseye womp rats in my t-16
back home
chapter 5 of the book of boba fett also
features a return cameo by new republic
captain carson teva played by paul sun
hyung lee captain teva appeared in two
episodes of the mandalorian the
passenger and the siege and famously
saved denjarin grogu and the frog lady
from certain death at the hands of giant
ice spiders in return of the mandalorian
captain teva and another new republic
officer pull over din's n1 starfighter
for speeding too close to a commercial
ship the three men can't see each other
through their ships but captain teva
recognizes den's voice and tries to ask
him some questions about reported
imperial remnants on the planet navarro
din then flees law enforcement and heads
back to tatooine and pelimoto's mose
eisley body shop
when denjarin visits pelimoto's shop we
get a look at the plethora of droids she
employs to help her fix up starships
besides a bd droid straight out of jedi
fallen order eagle-eyed star wars fans
will see the return of an astromech
droid that is pivotal in luke skywalker
getting r2d2 and c-3po from the jawas in
the very first star wars film r5d4 is
seen rolling through pelly's shop still
sporting the hole in his top where his
busted motivator exploded right after
luke and uncle owen bought the droid in
a new hope however the book of boba fett
chapter 5 isn't r5's first reappearance
since the empire fell the droid was also
seen at chalman's spaceport cantina when
din arrived searching for work and later
at the mos eisley spaceport after peli
acquired the droid
the sixth episode of the book of boba
fett spends a lot of time with grogu and
luke skywalker who is training the
little green guy in the ways of the
force as part of his efforts to rebuild
the jedi order another part of those
efforts seems to be building a new jedi
temple which a bunch of ant droids are
seen doing in this episode by the end of
the episode the first part of the new
temple is complete and it looks a bit
like the more developed temple that is
seen being destroyed in luke's flashback
in star wars the last jedi presumably
those androids stayed busy after grogu
left
since the sixth episode largely covers
grogu's jedi training it's not
surprising that the scenes were chock
full of callbacks to luke's time
training with yoda on dagobah in the
empire strikes back luke is now the
master and it's touching to see him use
the same lessons phrases and physical
maneuvers to show grogu his potential in
wielding the force luke even brings back
some of yoda's famous phrases like size
matters not and a tweaked version of do
or do not there is no try in another
scene luke wears grogu in a backpack and
runs leaps and flips through the bamboo
forest before climbing up a stalk to
show grogu how beautiful and vast this
planet and the whole galaxy can be this
quick paced scene is a direct nod to
luke doing the same thing with yoda on
his back
in the book of boba fett episode 7 the
season finale a new type of battle droid
is introduced the scorpenectroid the
pike syndicate unleashes two of these
huge and deadly droids on boba fett's
crew while they try to fight off the
pikes and protect mose espa luckily boba
has a rancor and a little green force
sensitive who can help him take down
these droids and win the war for boba
fett and crew in the star wars legends
continuity scorpenectroids were used by
the separatists during the clone wars
along with the familiar droidikas both
types of droids had rapid-fire laser
cannons and deployed nearly impenetrable
deflector shields the scorpenec droid
was first mentioned in the book the new
essential guide to droids and its
concept art appears to be an early form
of what would become the droidica in
star wars attack of the clones
boba fett and cadbane have a long
history dating back to the prequel era
and the latter learned the bounty
hunting ways from the former's father
jango fett the two bounty hunters have
had a tolerate hate relationship for
decades and they reunite in the book of
boba fett episode 7. boba is working for
himself and his people and bane is being
paid by the pikes to enforce the flow of
spice in the area this leads to a battle
between the two parties and an epic duel
between boba and bane the duel ends in
boba's favor with him stabbing bane with
his tuscan gaffy stick interestingly the
clash echoes the one from an unfinished
episode of the clone wars in the unaired
arc the duel between the two bounty
hunters shows them squaring off on
tatooine and shooting each other the
unfinished scene shows how boba got the
circular dent in his helmet which is
still there even after being repainted
though it wasn't clear in the unfinished
episode bane appears in the bad batch
with a metal plate on his head hinting
that boba shot him in the head during
the duel in the book of boba fett season
finale the metal plate is shown again
when bane's hat is knocked off all but
confirming the unfinished episode is
part of the canon
before their final duel in chapter seven
boba fett and cad bane trade barbs in a
nod to their fraught history over the
decades at one point bane says
if that's not the quack to call in the
stiffling slimy
that's basically the star wars version
of the pot calling the kettle black and
it's not the first time we've heard this
phrase in a star wars television series
in the mandalorian season 2 finale din
and boba meet with bo katan kris and
koska reeves to enlist their help in
rescuing grogu from the imperial
clutches of moff gideon with all four of
them being mandalorians in some way they
all have different views on the way
mandalorians should act as such the two
women don't like boba and he doesn't
like them while trading barbs before
their weapons come out koska says i
didn't know sidekicks were allowed to
talk boba responds by saying well if
that isn't the quack to calling the
stiffling slimy boba's remark is meant
to poke at koska's place as bogotan's
sidekick but it seems the phrase is
pretty popular among bounty hunters
with the conclusion of season 1 of the
book of boba fett the clone and
ex-bounty hunter is now the godfather of
tatooine fittingly in the season finale
there are two key callbacks to the
godfather films the first comes when
boba sends the former mayor's twilike
major domo out to share his terms of
surrender with the pikes the major domo
reads boba's words on his tablet telling
the pikes he offers them nothing this
speech echoes the one by michael
corleone in the godfather part 2. you
can have my answer now if you like
my offer is this
nothing
and in the end of the episode after boba
and his crew win the battle and restore
peace he and fennick walk the streets of
mo's espa one citizen comes up to boba
and offers him a melee run fruit which
boba gives to chrysanton this moment is
a subtle nod to don corleone receiving
gifts of fruit from those he ruled over
in the godfather 2 but in filming style
it's arguably more reminiscent of the
simpsons parody of the godfather 2. don
hopper i have baked a special donut just
for you
since the premiere of return of the jedi
in 1983 fans have been wondering if and
how boba fed escaped the sarlacc pit and
the retconned star wars legends
continuity boba escapes the pit using
his jet pack as seen in the 1983 comic
star wars number 81 titled jawas of doom
and in the 1996 story a barf like that
boba also escapes the sarlacc via his
jetpack this time by telepathically
communicating with another victim inside
the beast and tricking the creature into
launching his weapon boba's canonical
escape from the sarlacc in episode 1 of
the book of boba fett is similar to the
legends one but in the book of boba fett
the iconic bounty hunter unleashes a
flamethrower on his wrist gauntlet to
burn the creature from the inside and
claw his way up through the deep sandy
pit
blink and you'll miss the wreckage of
jabba the hutt's iconic sailing barge
the katana in the scene of boba fett
emerging from the sarlacc pit in episode
1. in the original trilogies finale film
the chaotic fighting and the epic death
of jabba at the hands of leia also
resulted in the destruction of the
katana destroyed beyond repair and no
longer with a captain it was left to rot
on the sands above the pit of carcoon in
the book of boba fett the remains of the
destroyed barge can be seen behind boba
at the edge of the pit as he claws his
way to the surface and collapses on the
sand where sure the katana has been
picked clean of any valuables over the
years by some jawas just as they do to
an unconscious boba in the first episode
the mysterious spider droid carrying a
fishbowl of orange red liquid is
actually a member of the ancient bomar
order a religious sect whose members
transplanted their brains into these
bowls and used these spider droids to
move about in order to focus all
sensation and attention on their minds a
bomar order spider droid first appeared
in return of the jedi in 1983 in a short
scene that shows one of them walking by
an open door in jabba's palace according
to star wars lore these monks were the
original owners of the palace and
mozespa until jabba took over in the
book of boba fett it appears there are
still some members of the bomar order
left on tatooine as the opening scene of
episode 3 shows a spider droid scuttling
past the exterior of the palace
are these the droids you're looking for
in the book of boba fett's first episode
two droids in particular stood out hd8
and r3x aka rex 8d8 is a humanoid-esque
smelter droid that was last seen as a
torturer in return of the jedi in the
book of boba fett 88 is now a butler of
sorts helping introduce the colors
coming to greet and pay tribute to
tatooine's new crime lord the droid's
mention of tortured screams of the
gomorian guards he drags in is a subtle
nod to his previous sadistic role for
jabba those two gomorian guards are also
very likely the same ones who served
jabba in return of the jedi these two
gomorians were once body guides to jabba
the hat and later bib fortuna
they did not surrender even after their
patron was killed
the other recognizable droid r3x is
lifted from disney's theme parks in
particular galaxy's edge at disney world
and disneyland r3x had a long history as
the fun pilot of star tours but most
recently took another gig as a dj at
ogus cantina in blackspire outpost in
the book of boba fed r3x is seen playing
a dealer at the most espa casino
a tatooine cantina wouldn't be the same
without the planet's most famous tunes
luckily the book of boba fett brings
back two of the galaxy's most famous
musicians for a hefty dose of nostalgia
inside the moe's espa venue patrons are
imbibing and betting while a funky remix
of the classic cantina band song is
played by none other than max rebo and
figrin dan max rebo is a blue skinned
elephant-like creature who is
understandably presumed dead after last
being seen on jabba's sailing barge but
it looks like he's alive and well
alongside figure and dan the bith
musician a former member of the popular
band figure and dan and the modal nodes
played cantina band in the iconic scene
and mows eisley in a new hope though
he's without his other band members and
in a new town figrin dan seems to be
doing just fine playing tunes at the
moe's espa cantina with max rebo
boba fett may be down and out during his
imprisonment by the tuscan raiders but
he still knows how to kill a foe like
the best of them when he and a fellow
prisoner a rhodian dig for black melons
in the tattooing desert in episode 1 the
rodian awakens a multi-armed scaly beast
that attacks them and the young tuscan
raider they're with the goro-like
creature quickly kills the rodian and
goes after boba and the tuscan raider
next but boba uses his shackles and
chain to his advantage in a move
straight out of return of the jedi boba
swings the chain around the beast's neck
and pulls tight strangling it until it
falls he stands triumphantly atop the
creature holding his chains and
glowering at the tuscan raider it's a
moment where boba earns some respect
from his captors but also one eerily
similar to the way princess leia killed
jabba the hutt by strangling him with
her chains
showrunner and director robert rodriguez
has a key cameo in the series premiere
stranger in a strange land rodriguez
portrays dog strassie the leader of the
trandocian family who works under jabba
the hutt on tatooine in the first
episode dokstrassi greets boba and gives
him a tribute in the form of wookie pelt
during the exchange boba remarks on the
awkwardness of the situation since he
had worked for the trendocion at one
point in his bounty hunting career and
now dokstrassi serves him as joke stress
he leaves the throne room of now boba's
palace he tells him may you never leave
mo's espa even when a trend ocean pays
you a compliment it sounds like a threat
one of the most jaw-dropping moments in
the book of boba fett is the surprise
live-action introduction of wookie
gladiator black cursantin in episode 2
the tribes of tatooine star wars comics
fans know the towering all-black wookie
gladiator and bounty hunter black
chrysanthemum from when he was
introduced in 2015 in marvel's darth
vader series black chrysanthen also
known as santi bk and black k is also a
fan favorite character in the dr aphra
comics in the lore shown in the comics
black cursantin was taken from his
homeworld of kashyyyk and trained to be
a gladiator in fighting pits black
chrysanthen eventually becomes a bounty
hunter and works for jabba and at one
point works alongside boba fett it's
likely moses espa's new boss knows
exactly what the ruthless wookie is
capable of when they reunite in episode
2.
it might be a little late for luke
skywalker to snag some power converters
but it wasn't too late for star wars to
reveal tashi's station and show what the
jedi's childhood best friends are up to
take these two over to the garage will
you i want them cleaned up for dinner
but i was going into toshi station to
pick up some power converters you can
waste time with your friends when your
chores are done while boba fett brings
an epic beat down to the local menacing
swoop bike gang in episode 2 two humans
are cowering and trying to avoid the
mayhem these two humans a man and a
woman are never named in the episode but
they are most certainly luke's friends
cami and fixer and this small cantina is
toshi station the brief shots of the
building's exterior and interior
architecture show details that match the
deleted scene of toshi station from the
first star wars movie in 1977. for those
original details from the original film
kami and fixer were around luke's age
and hung out often at tashi station kami
is also referenced in the last jedi
novel when luke dreams about what his
life would have been like if he never
left tatooine and married cammy instead
though their appearances are brief the
cammy and fixer cameos are a fun subtle
nod to original star wars details that
ended up on the cutting room floor
being such a star wars fan it's no
surprise that executive producer robert
rodriguez has made more than one cameo
in the show in episode two that comes in
the form of moze espa's ethorian mayor
who may or may not have hired an
assassin to take out or test boba fett
in episode one the mayor's major domo
appears in boba's new court as a
representative of the mayor's office
both boba and fenik shand feel insulted
by the mayor not coming himself but in
episode two the two groups finally meet
the mayor is mock chaiez an ethorian who
communicates via a translator headpiece
aka the voice of rodriguez
is that so
i've heard otherwise
the mayor rebuffs boba's and fenix
allegations that he sent an assassin
after him and even thanks boba for
bringing in the assassin for punishment
he's quickly executed besides handing
boba and fennick a sack of coins mayor
mock chaiez offers his tribute of advice
about running a family and tells him to
see madame garceth whip for the latest
news about his position on mo's espa
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
star wars are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]